you got a race right now for senate in
pennsylvania
the race is between two people dr oz
who as far as i can tell
is half a democrat at least and was just
on radioed
attacking pro-life bills very very
recently until he decided he wanted to
become the republican nominee for senate
and was castigating
pro-lifers
and
i i've never heard the man articulate
any particularly conservative point of
view in my life but he won the
nomination for for that seat so and
unfortunately with trump's endorsement
so you got dr oz as the republican
candidate and you got this guy john
fetterman who is who is the democratic
nominee john fetterman is one of the
goofiest
candidates i have ever seen on the
campaign trail here just to give you a
little flavor if you haven't watched too
much here's fetterman
and you can count
on us
to eliminate the filibuster
if you
come out
and step with us
we will be able to stand with you in dc
i gave away the lieutenant governor
governor in pennsylvania the only
lieutenant governor in the history to do
that and let's
let's get some stuff
done for america who would ever think
that i would be
the normal the normal one in the race
area
john fetterman makes joe biden look
lucid
john fetterman makes joe biden look like
a rhodes scholar
this guy
not a whole lot going on between the
ears john fetterman i'm not sure that
he's ever earned a dollar in his life
through actual work it just came out
that that this guy who positions himself
as a working-class hero he's the working
man's candidate he wears hoodies he's
got his little goatee thing he's a cool
tough working guy from pennsylvania
turns out this guy's basically never
worked in honesty in his life he was
getting an allowance from his parents to
subsidize his political career the money
that he was bringing in it was when we
talk allowance when i was a kid i got
one dollar a week allowance sometimes
and i didn't even get it all the time
john fetterman was getting over 50 grand
a year from his parents okay this guy is
such a
cartoonishly bad candidate
his his policy issues
his policy positions are absolutely
terrible when they're coherent at all
his health is not all that great so he's
been off the campaign trail for a
long period of time when he comes back
on frankly he was doing better when he
was off the campaign trail
this should be a slam dunk
win
and here is how
dr oz is attacking john federer here is
the campaign ad that dr oz just posted
from his own personal account
now that john fetterman claims to be
recovering let's pull back his hoodie
and examine what's in his head
looks like he has some screws loose
what's this
fetterman wants to release one third of
all prisoners that's crazy
spend more tax dollars everything will
cost more that's nuts
slow energy production
gas prices will skyrocket
that's ridiculous
[Applause]
[Music]
john fetterman is crazier than you think
that is and i don't think i'm
exaggerating here
the worst political ad i have ever seen
and i've i've seen a lot of political
ads remember i am not a witch christine
o'donnell you remember the demon sheep
ad you remember i've seen there have
been so many terrible
advertisements
i don't know that any of them have ever
been worse than that one because that ad
makes me
more inclined to support jon fetterman
that attack ad
makes jon fetterman look better than he
actually is
just makes him seem kind of silly
you know it just makes him seem kind of
oh he's got those big googly eyes that's
kind of fun no the guy's very very
dangerous
he's
his policies would be absolutely
terrible for pennsylvania
absolutely terrible for the united
states
he should not be trusted with power
he's not who he says he is he's a liar
he's deceitful
no no he's just a wacky wakka wakka and
then what then half of the ad it's just
silly little marionettes and puppets of
aoc and bernie sanders who care what are
you talking about so it should be about
fetterman and how terrible he is john
fetterman is a much worse candidate than
aoc or bernie sanders bernie sanders has
been in american politics for half a
century bernie sanders is a fairly
popular
candidate actually
even aoc she's pretty shrewd politician
why on earth would you take the
attention off of him
i'm not is is dr oz getting a payoff
from the democrats here
i don't know i don't know what to make
of it
it's really really unfortunate though
john fetterman this just came out from
washington free beacon he he voted to
free a convicted murderer who killed an
18 year old for heroin money
he's very frequently the sole
pennsylvania board of pardons member to
vote for freeing murderers put that in a
campaign ad
don't put aoc as a jack in the box what
is wrong with these
people not a good way to win a race
maybe dr oz is just there to lose the
race i don't know i don't know what he's
doing unfortunately right now head on
over to goodranchers.com
michael our friends over at good
ranchers are on a mission to donate 100
000 high quality meals this month to
children in need to help them reach
their goal 10 lucky listeners who
purchase a box of my absolute favorite
meat delicious american meat from
goodranchers.commichael
will win a 30-minute zoom call
experience with me on september 30th you
know what we're calling it we're calling
it a meet and greet do you get it you
better you better hurry up and sign up
right now this offer is only valid
through august 31st buy from
goodranchers.com michael save 30 on your
box of 100 american meat plus free
shipping and be entered to win a 30
minute zoom session with me off the
clock
let's help these guys reach their goal
of 100 000 donated meals this month and
then you and i can hang out in a meet
and greet
and maybe who knows maybe i'll be eating
good ranchers during the meet and greet
i'm not sure all i know is i eat good
ranchers pretty much three times a week
i absolutely adore their meats you will
too head on over goodranchers.com
michael i'm so glad you like that clip
now
you got to ring the bell you got to
subscribe we hit a million subscribers i
love that we got to go to a billion we
have to we have no other choice ring
that bell get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you